hey everybody in the studio can I have
your attention for a second here
Nick Nick attention we have a drive with
errors on the corridor rate it's showing
that the the drive is at risk so you
guys have important files now's the time
to go with me into the back room and
verify they are copied over me no we
went over this and when and when the
raid broke down the first time I was
like Nico you shouldn't do a raid system
again any second oh and here we are less
than two years later budget pubsey yet
but this origin computer sound driver
keeps crashing have you seen the latest
edit I'm expecting that Samms put his
own twist on it and the surprise some
good ideas in there I'm also expecting
it to miss a couple of things I'm trying
to do with it it'll probably be the
cases I'll probably work in the beats
that I'm looking for and keep a lot of
the cool like snappy stuff that Sam's
worked in as well some things especially
in action scenes you don't they don't
register until the piece is completely
done because there's visual effects
sound and music that contribute towards
certain things being recognizable beats
of the scene interesting ideas in there
but a lot of the pacing is very
different than what I'm looking for to
edit it to be what I intended when we
did lifeline well we've got notes from a
billion different people so you know all
the townspeople are working on it they
didn't do a bad job or anything like
that but with the corridor channel right
now I'm a little bit that baggage where
when I direct something right now I want
it to be exactly what I want it to be
maybe to the detriment of the piece who
knows and got Merlin's pants fantastic
subscribe and track record with the
videos in the channel this year so
you're going to go back on somebody's
work if you're going to change it like I
need to I need to get it really polished
because I can't just show like a janky
rough cut of my idea because it's gonna
look like garbage up against an actual
refined edit no matter what kind of edit
that is if I don't get this edit done
before Sam gets back from his trip it's
going to be a lot harder for me to make
this edit reflect what I was trying to
do
directing the piece because everybody's
going to look at my edit if it's not
finished and just think it looks way
worse than what Sam's put together
servers acting up a little bit so came
here to restart it I don't know
everything's backed up to a few days ago
yeah but we've done a lot of stuff since
ok chemical data dumps use I'm thinking
and it's kind of risky but it'd be the
fastest option I backup our most recent
projects onto a third backup I also
backup a couple for like are essential
operating things like the FX materials
sound all that kind of stuff I go to a
completely fresh set of drives wipe them
drop the new stuff on there but for that
one moment when their wife to only have
everything in one spot I don't like that
idea
really
there's backup right now it's fine
vacker bring back some every night until
no one checks it and there's power loss
and then it is a week of work
anyway well I'm trying to do is
summarize the entire Bill of Rights
in 30 seconds the raid is down and I
can't work on the pub to get it so I
gotta fix the raid first before I can
work on the pub G of it right now
I need to spend the day working on the
frickin raid and not on my edits so this
whole goal getting this done is getting
pushback wanna see Sam get some back
dude that was the longest drought of my
life what drives yeah we're having a
drive supporting errors on the raid so
everything's all backed up onto the back
of raid at this point with me about to
do a triplicate backup before jumping in
- you're fixing the main raid cool oh
yeah this is hard I need a Spencer you
like to drive yeah I don't know it's
criminals just like he loves puns
because he's talking about disk drives
now because we have a bad one in the
corridor aid with what they were playing
choppy
everything else is generally copping
over pretty quick there's one file in
particular that's not reading any
program what's that it's good plugin
particular truck deep learnings it is
there's there's a Western Digital
program you can get then we'll do a
smart test so just I would love to get
back on here and edit though I shall do
after lunch so
i sat down and basically what a couple
things I really liked that opening shot
with the force field right at the top
like that's great in Carmichael at a
suggestion which is to make that shot
either the POV of the c-130 or have the
c-130 enter the shop on I went back and
I wanted to just try editing what I had
directed for you'll notice there's a lot
of stuff not used slash cut with the guy
the the anonymous squad a lot of time on
set was spent filming these close-up
shots yeah these guys they literally
have numbers next to their names in the
script they could not be any more
meaningless you know enemy one enemy
tickets like I would just say like my
main critique of the the process from
filming it to editing it to like one
will end up being the final product
though I think bringing a little more
clear direction into how you shoot this
opening scene not the right note the
running was like five shots but then
there's you see there's this block of
like seventeen clips that these just
guys walking around talking and we're
gonna spend up no time with these
characters in the final piece so it's
like taking some of that forethought and
bringing it to onset there to just kind
of make things a little more spend less
time shooting it knowing you're not
gonna need a lot of footage focus on
maybe the fight sequence or so you know
that kind of thing yeah so that's that's
my big critique that I just need to get
out of the way because that's good
actually
come I got a good suggestion yeah scene
2 which is up to that point up to the
scene where they stop and they're
watching the trees everything's very
handheld for with them or in the action
and then we got a couple of those dolly
shots so if you actually commit to no
handheld stuff like so it's like you're
in the action the action running jumping
shrinked keep the hides and boom dolly
shots you save the dolly shots until
they can vacate Dave and Jane Goethe
health oh so it's like you're like
you're with him you're with him you're
like out watching as the third part
party viewer like you know getting
cinematic and boom back into it and
that's actually there's a really nice
cinematography change there's an egg
there's actual bots on YouTube that's
content that scan the image of the
thumbnail skin tags one of the things
that some of the bots look for are
inappropriate languages with it and they
have a list of words and what they the
words would sound like so the safest way
to do it is try to incorporate bleeping
outwards what if we didn't use normal
bleeps and like we actually just
recorded in dude that sent one Sam like
Samuel just like I can't even explain it
it's like basically it so like I think
let's go record some Sam so we want to
start bleeping out swear words on the
channel and but we don't want to use
bleach yeah Superboy so could we get
some of your famous the screams your
screams I just let me see you when
you're really ain't gonna do like
bleeping it with like our nation has
ever seen Sam he's angry he's really
scary 101 great swear slash cuss word
alternatives kids what are they Merlin's
pants
Ceaser's ghosts fiddlesticks love that
one
snicker doodles well how these are like
this the worst that is I just sent John
slack the advertisers guideline or
advertising friendly guideline words and
how words sound are being searched
through YouTube videos via BOTS to be d
monetized shells but
[Laughter]
[Music]
Fiddlesticks subscribe subscribe
subscribe swear words and then try to
pronounce them Jam reconvey okay David
Jane Goethe farting like a sheepdog on a
short chain that's what I just said look
like just say sentence with a bunch of
swear words in it go you will never go
on the Internet perfect nice net now say
a sentence that incorporates swear words
but there are some words in between that
aren't so I was like have you ever seen
those mother smart subscribe for a zoo
always suck my bill weed small they're
gonna kill the shoe dad mother for
Merlin's pants great if that could never
go on the internet ever hey what's up
which [ __ ] are the best lets to go by
that's let's ago why here you see it was
ill to bat alright now it's our Lud pack
what
what will the look what yeah that's
right actually guys I haven't hard at
work for the past week here taking some
of our best looking videos and making
look-up tables for them basically look
presets are literally taking the color
grades that I have made for our videos
and I'm doing to you guys well for a
price because I put a lot of work into
them trying to make sure they even work
across a whole bunch of different types
of footage and making sure I get about
vlog versions
rec.709 versions anyways in other words
we are selling some of our looks from
our videos our color grades if you guys
would like to check them out head on
over to Creator presets calm as where
they are on sale along with a whole
bunch of other look-up tables and
presets and I think Lightroom presets as
well for photography
Sawyer Hartman a friend of ours is
putting it together he wanted to
basically create a way that different
youtubers and photographers and
instagramers could all get together and
share some of the tools of what they do
how would people like you
animated spinner nerf Team Fortress with
like the punchy kind of oranges and reds
that really bring out the nerf guns who
color grades from the division which
give us like a really gritty cinematic
look I really hips third film grade from
the Master Chief doesn't want to die
video I have Jason Bourne teaches
Thanksgiving everybody does the
Hollywood blue and teal these days but
this one takes a step in the yellow and
green direction we have nerf John wick a
second favorite one in the bunch which
is the poacher color grade and they
spent a long time on that back in the
day putting it together no one really
makes any forest scene just come to life
really well we have my favorite one the
Assassin's Creed 3 is summer to fall
look thank you oh wow so this is what
it's like summertime so it's like wow so
sorry time well you can use this in any
program that supports look-up tables
heck even like put it into your monitor
for your camera if it sports that so you
can actually see your footage through a
lookup table which is pretty cool and
technical you're gonna get eighteen
because you're getting a log version and
a rec 709 version of each one
[Music]